CARE ABOUT TRUTH ANYMORE OR
CIVIL LIBERTIES APPARENTLY.
JOINING US NOW, TEXAS
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
BY THE WAY, WHAT A BEAT DOWN OF
POOR CHUCKY.
IT'S LIKE -- SIT HIM DOWN, PULL
THEM UP AGAIN, HIT HIM AGAIN.
GREAT JOB.
>> THAT WAS FUN.
>> Tucker: THIS IS SERIOUS
STUFF YOU WE'VE GOT A DIRTY
DOSSIER PAID FOR.
EVERYBODY SEEMS TO CARE ABOUT
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE BUT NOT
THAT.
YOU HEAR THE COMMENTS OF BOTH
DURHAM AND BARR.
>> IT'S CHILLING TO HEAR THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT.
THE ABUSE OF POWER WE SAW IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND IT
CONTINUED IN THE DEEP STATE FOR
THE FIRST COUPLE OF YEARS, YOU
SAW THE ABUSE OF POWER AT THE
FBI, THE ABUSE OF POWER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I'VE GOT TO SAY, AS AN ALUMNUS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, I
AM ANGRY.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHO ARE
ANGRY READING THIS REPORT.
THE VERY BEST INTERPRETATION OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT IS
THAT THE FBI AND DEPARTING OF
JUSTICE WERE MANIFESTLY
INCOMPETENT, THE IG REPORT
OUTLINES 17 FACTUAL
MISSTATEMENTS THAT THEY MADE TO
THE FISA COURT AND THEY WERE
NEGLIGENT IN ORDERING THE
SURVEILLANCE, SPYING OF A
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE AND A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
THAT'S THE MOST FAVORABLE
INTERPRETATION FOR THE MOST REAL
INTERPRETATION IS THESE WERE
HARDCORE POLITICAL PARTISANS WHO
HATED DONALD TRUMP AND THEY WERE
WILLING AND COMPLICIT TO ABUSE
THE POWER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INTELLIGENCE AND SPY ON A
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
>> Tucker: CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
CAUSE ADDITIONAL RIGHTS,
SOMETHING WE BOTH CARE ABOUT.
WHAT YOU SEE THIS HEADING?
>> THAT'S THE SECOND PETE WHY
IT'S ENCOURAGING.
I THINK THIS IG REPORT IS THE
FIRST STEP IN THE WRONGDOER IS
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
I WAS VERY ENCOURAGED BOTH BY
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR A
STATEMENT AND DURHAM STATEMENT
THAT MORE COUNTABILITY WILL COME
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLB
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLE
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLH
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLL
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLD
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLH
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLE
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLA
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLC
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLU
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILLT
AND THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER WILL.
I'LL TELL YOU WHY WHY I'M ALSO
ENCOURAGED.
BECAUSE THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC
SHOW TRIAL IN THE HOUSE IS
COLLAPSING.
WE ARE SEEING THE MEDIA
PANICKING.
TALK ABOUT CHUCK DIED YESTERDAY.
THE MEDIA IS IN FULL ON PANIC
BECAUSE WHAT THEY HOPE TO THIS
IMPEACHMENT WOULD PROVE HASN'T
BEEN PROVING IT AND IT'S LIKE
RATS FLEEING SINKING SHIP.
THE HOUSE I ASSUME IS GOING TO
HAVE A PARTISAN VOTE.
IT'S GOING TO THE SENATE AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO GO ANYWHERE IN
THE SENATE.
WE ARE GOING TO THROW IT OUT AND